[Music]
always remember the universe has a way
of leading into where you're supposed to
be at the moment you're supposed to be
there let's do this
it took me 20 years to find you
you can say that
you are the best-kept secret in the
universe and I found you
which makes be perfect for this job you
really think a black suit he's going to
solve all your problems
no but looks damn good on you we
[Music]
recognizable only as deja vu and
dismissed just as quickly trying to
prove yourself agent M we may have a
puppy in London
welcome to MIB you will be with Asian
treats one of the best ever to weather
suit
[Music]
catching up on my daily meditation time
for lunch I thank you hungry
it's 9:30 Tuesdays taco day we've been
compromised with every citizen of this
planet at risk
[Applause]
you could all just look right here just
try
it'll be fun left fun with it
there should be a big red button around
here somewhere found it we are the men
and black
looks like a tables of 10
welcome to rhyme city a celebration of
the harmony between humans and pokémon
Tim your dad was a legend in this
precinct before you were anything like
your talent
I remember you wanted to be a pokémon
trainer anyway yeah yeah they didn't
really work out
[Music]
come in there whoever you are and not to
use this jeez here we go
I know you can't understand me but put
down the stapler or I will electrocute
you did you just talk whoa did you just
understand me oh my god you can
understand me but I've been so lonely
they try to talk to me all the time all
they hear is pika pika you can hear him
right guys adorable you're adorable they
can't understand me kiss you no one else
here I told me to Pokemon period and
what about a world-class detective
because if you want to find your pops
I'm your best bet we're gonna do this
you and me
[Music]
it brought us together and that magic is
called hope
listen up we got ways to make you talk
or mine yeah tell us what we want to
know pike yes okay I can shoving pushing
my problem is that I push people away
and then hate them for leaving he's
saying you can shove it what I can shove
it okay that's it no we're switching
roles I'm bad cop you're good cop in my
head I saw that differently
[Music]
I'm so good hey sorry I'm late
happy nice thank you you too thank you
new dress yes it is in fact you know
what just happened
[Music]
[ __ ] passport Peter Parker here to pick
up a passport please
a a toothpaste let's go pack your suit I
just want to go on my trip with my
friends Europe doesn't really need it
friendly enumerates
you look really pretty therefore I have
value no it's not
you look pretty too my first love I just
finished my phone call so nice to
finally meet you
in spite of man you're Nick Fury put
some clothes on let's go for a ride is
she gonna be okay like that might want
to turn him over so he doesn't swallow
his tongue
Nick Fury just hijacked our summer
vacation
awesome
get gifts Parker but we have a job to do
are you going to step up or not
your friends are in trouble
what are you gonna do about it
you don't want any part of this
who is that guy he's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one he's no spider-man
what is it with you and spider-man what
he looks out for the neighborhood has a
dope suit and I really respect him
sup dickwad
[Applause]
[Music]
the world as we know it ended in 2018
the war between the Earth and the moon
Nazis had led to all-out nuclear
destruction
the last survivors of the healing race
made the refuge on the Dark Side of the
Moon the exiled remnants of humankind
made their new home in the former Nazi
base
[Music]
the moon is not going to be here for
long we head to the center of the earth
which is apparently Hollow and hopefully
find the one thing that can save my mom
basically the whole of mankind okay cool
can I go
machine is online
the Holy Grail huh
what was that
you think you can fix me gee you are not
broken
beautiful friend mind is a fragile thing
takes only the slightest tap to tip it
in the wrong direction
Charles what did you do I had to keep a
stable I protected her from the truth
there's another word for that I came
looking for answers you feel like you
don't belong here
you don't they can't begin to comprehend
what you are she's changing to what you
didn't come here looking for answers you
came here looking for permission
she's old range
Hey missile coming out of us Jean lost
control
was she still our friend this is your
fault Charles the world is on the brink
I'm sorry I didn't stop it sooner you're
always sorry Charles
and as always a speech and nobody cares
there still
don't do this
[Music]
the right to fear me I've seen Abel
[Music]
I'm looking at it now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
does it bother you that I'm not too
completely human
you were the most human person I have
ever met
[Music]
didn't I tell you to be home before dark
I just lost track of time
bolita you have to be responsible
where's someone very special hey kid not
just a teenage girl hey what's your
problem you can't remember what do you
mean doc found you in the scrap yard so
you must be from up there and I'm just
an insignificant girl that's what they
want you to think
I'm not your daughter I don't know what
I am I do
yet the most advanced weapon ever
but that's just a shell it's not bad or
good that part's up to you
I do not stand by
the presence of evil
she's threatening the natural order of
things
tonight is not a game
it is a heart
I need you to destroy the girl called
Aleta
we made the biggest mistake of your life
and what's that
under estimating who I am
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
staying on
hey miss Potts if you find this
recording don't feel bad about this part
of the journey use the end
just for the record being adrift in
space with zero promise of rescue is
more fun than it sounds
food and water went out four days ago
officers will run out tomorrow morning
back then when I drift off I will dream
that you toys you
[Music]
[Music]
danos did exactly what he said he was
gonna do
he wiped out 50% of all living creatures
we lost all of us
Plus friends you lost family
we lost a part of ourselves
this is the fight of our lives this is
gonna work Steve I know it is cuz I
don't know what I'm gonna do if it
doesn't
hi is anyone home this is Scott Lang we
met a few years ago at the airport in
Germany that got really big it's just an
old message I know you know that
that's me can you buzz me in
hello
is anyone there
I'm trying to reach
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
senators we believe that these Titans
are just the tip of the iceberg which of
these Titans are here to protect us and
[Music]
which of these Titans are here to
threaten us
so you'd want to make Godzilla our pet
no we would be his you're sure he's
gonna be okay
they're everywhere battling for
dominance
arrival outfit to go Dylan you gotta be
kidding
[Music]
[Music]
you've run from foster homes in six
counties I can take care of myself when
you're 18 give these people a chance
because that's what they're giving you
[Music]
this is Billy Batson make sure you make
him feel at home
they seem nice but don't buy it
it gets real gameofthrones around here
dude just mess around you look at me and
you're like why so dark you're disabled
foster kid you've got it all Vince you
could have one superpower what would you
think everybody chooses flight you know
why so they can fly away from this
conversation no cuz hero's fly well you
need your fake family to stand up for
you
man sorry about that
Billy Batson I choose you
escape
hello
say my name so my powers may flow
through you but I don't know your names
through wait for you okay
Shazam
Billy you're the only person I know that
knows anything about this Cape Crusader
stuff tonight yeah it's crazy right
what are your superpowers superpowers
dude I don't even know how to pee in
this thing just can you fly if I quit
you're okay why are you sucking your
co-stars your phone charge like a bad
guy right
you have full immunity I'm bulletproof
you're dead sorry about your window
you're welcome for not getting robbed
oh hey stop I'm a superhero so scrolls
are the bad guys
and you're a Cree a race of noble
warriors heroes noble warrior heroes
[Music]
your life began the day it nearly ended
we found you with no memory we made you
one of us so you could live longer
stronger superior
you were reborn
I keep having these
memories something in my past is the key
to all of this
you know how to Bladensburg you'll see
that's a yes or no question yes
[Music]
would you like to know
but you really are
I think I had a life here
what aren't you telling me
you've come a long way
but you know as strong as you think
[Music]
the school is just the beginning
I'm not gonna fight your war
[Music]
I'm gonna end it
[Music]
[Music]
I'm sOooo cute as love thing are you
what's your name
[Music]